football 17 millions de francs c'est le
montant de la transaction de didier
deschamps à l'olympique de marseille
l'international nantais a quitté son
club hier
un départ qui a été diversement
appréciée pour le maire de nantes cette
transaction jeu le site illustre les
spirales du fric dans le football
français
en revanche elle arrange plutôt les
finances du club nantais didier
deschamps 21 en partance pour
l'olympique de marseille déjà arrivé à
nantes patrice héraud 22 ans tous deux
semblent un peu perdus dans ce monde du
football bernard tapie lui voulait
deschamps le transfert s'est conclu
dimanche soir et deschamps est transféré
à l'olympique de marseille pour une
somme donc de 17 millions de francs
et en plus on obtient le prêt de patrice
héraud durant un an et demi avec une
option pour l'acquisition de ce joueur
c'est c'est pas bonne affaire quand même
pour le fc nantes de perdre son affiche
vous en aviez fait le symbole de l'année
je sais pas si on peut dire que c'est
une bonne affaire
je pense que dans la vie on veut faire
des choix
malheureusement je suis obligée de
choisir entre un homme et mon club je
faisais mon club
deschamps était la vitrine du fcn formé
à nantes il avait connu toutes les
sélections
j'ai passé c'est ainsi j'ai fait toute
ma ferme à la formation manger tout à
fait à nantes
bon ben nantes a pris des décisions
savons qu'ils sont tombés d'accord avec
marseille
à partir de là c'était à moi en prendre
note et puis bon j'ai eu une opportunité
et puis je les ai prises je crois que
j'ai fait un choix et puis bon c'est pas
c'est pas si mûrement réfléchie je crois
que c'est c'est très bien pour moi et
j'espère que le club
il trouvera son compte par la même
occasion